[Musik]
das ist extrem bitter
einfach erschreckend wenn sie der
eigenen sind mütter machen und hilfe für
ihre grundrechte also endzustand das
kind quasi als halbwaise zwei jahren
klappe und freiwillig wenn sich mal
vorstellen die hin dass wir zu begreifen
und dasselbe ordner also die würden sich
russell brand lang wie möglich
peter schlagmänner 43 reist nach
russland um nach zwei jahren funkstille
seine söhne wieder zu sehen
seine frau hat sie nach der trennung mit
nach sankt petersburg genommen
hier verliert sich ihre spur peter
schlag müller hofft verzweifelt dass
rené und andré heute sechs und vier
jahre alt bald wieder auftauchen
mein gott
[Musik]
es ist der 24
dezember 2019 nachmittags alle anderen
sind längst nach hause gegangen
peter schlag milder nicht denn in
erwarten traurige weihnachten in einer
leeren wohnung ohne seine kinder
es ist krass was momentan abgeht das ist
existenziell einzige was sie daheim ist
mein job vor mir da plan kriege und
rechtssicherheit gibt und im momentan
hand genau sagen wir das thema wasser er
trennte sich möchte aber nicht weiter
auf die gründe eingehen dass etwas
alleinige sorgerecht für seine söhne
bekam nützt ihm wenig denn seine frau
ist nach sieben jahren in ihrer heimat
russland untergetaucht zusammen mit den
kindern das war vor einem jahr
seither wohnt schlagmüller in einer
kleinen mansardenwohnung nahe zürich und
hofft doch noch zu seinem recht zu
kommen das heißt zu seinen kindern sieht
momentan ohne dass die gerichte des
aufwands denn da sind weil ich glaube
mit hochdruck noch fertig realisieren
wieso hat sie noch nicht fertig richtet
das ist genau der punkt wo mich
emotional immer wieder passiere wenn ich
jetzt dafür fertig realisieren und kind
nicht zu kämpfen wenn wir das extrem ich
aber ziehen das loch komisches download
bereit
schlafzimmer wo bei kriens sich
verbuchen der papi manchmal versteckt
sind oder sonst nachgerade als hypothek
auf früheren wohnsitz nach dem start
rissen die galaxie daheim unterstützung
bitter das ist hart aber ich habe das
gemacht und ich hoffe dass meine jungs
das neue regent ich werde einmal draußen
für sie wenn das problem hand seine
spätere frau lernte er vor zwölf jahren
im internet kennen einen ausdruck ihres
damaligen profilbildes hat er aufbewahrt
ich war sagt sie sich dann für jede frau
es ist sympathisch sieht offenheit hat
trainer über einige themen diskutieren
zukunftsplan was ist schon wichtig was
weniger wichtig international jungs
prägung sprachgewandtheit das sind so
impact sie warum ich überzogen hand sie
28 war im personalwesen tätig 432
kaufmann in einer gemeindeverwaltung
nach zwei jahren holte er sie aus
russland in die schweiz und heiratete
sie weitere drei jahre später kam das
erste kind ja auch hinter das ist ein
genie schnitt im lager wahlbezirk
grundlegend dort in ein anderes format
stelle aber ich kann grundsätzlich davor
muss oder hand dank das kind stabilität
der konsolidierung bringt bestätigung
von dem was man vorher erlebt hat dass
wir irgendwie oper nabucco die wilde
zeit nun vorbei
jetzt muss ich das fundament durch mit
drin zu meinem fuß quasi also sicherheit
heißt es für mich mit instabilität kind
geht man geborgenheit der schutzhülle
für ältere
wenn die 2018 reist ist eine frau mit
den kindern damals vier und zwei jahre
alt nach russland angeblich ferienhalber
der anfang eines alptraums im urin ist
so eine unruhe kreuz wächter halb stunde
lasse aber dann fängt es wieder auch
replay mehr wenn sie zeit zum überlegen
die einsamen moment danken sie wirke das
muss mir passieren
apokalypse total
die kinder seien hauptsächlich vom vater
betreut worden werden später
verschiedene zeugenaussagen frau und
mann werden angehört e mails und chat
verläufe ausgewertet aus all dem ergibt
sich ein gesamtbild für das
bezirksgericht dietikon es kommt 2009 10
zum schluss dass die mutter die kinder
aus druckmittel gegen den vater
einsetzen wolle
sie sei maßgeblich von egoistischen
motiven angetrieben und unterwerfe das
kindeswohl ihren eigenen interessen mit
ihn sei ihre erziehungsfähigkeit in
abrede zu stellen
der uetliberg liegt direkt vorschlag
will der haustür
hier war er regelmäßig mit seinen söhnen
und tricks wie ganz einfach schwierige
momente sehr emotional einfach ist es
für sie wenn sie als die familie gesamt
es ist ein verdrängungsprozess als
automatismus funktioniert wenn sie das
nicht bewältigen das login
tag für tag versucht er zu verdrängen
dass seine kinder plötzlich komplett aus
seinem leben verschwunden sind und er
keine ahnung hat wie es ihnen geht
häufig aber das gibt einem auftritt im
letzten jahr zog sie das hat mir die
stange gehalten
laut gericht brachte er die kinder
jeweils vor der arbeit in die krippe wo
es sie nach seinem feierabend wieder ab
holte er aus mit ihnen spielte mit ihnen
brachte es ins bett kurz die betreuung
der kinder im alltag habe hauptsächlich
er übernommen sofern sie nicht durch die
personen in der krippe betreut worden
seien
die mutter habe wenig interesse und den
buben gezeigt stellte das gericht fest
[Musik]
ich habe mal ein passant fand im dorf
angesprochen
wir haben sieht man nur leider sind sie
alleinerziehend darstellt speziell wenn
das umfeld wahrnimmt das einzig seit
januar sucht nach einer fuß flüchten
engagiert natürlich seinen lappen
situation
das ist klar umso bitterer ist es dass
er darunter prozent arbeitete
unternehmen alles für seine kinder tat
nun alleine dasteht
danke dass immer mehr junge mutter
darüber sind dass man viele ich mit dir
meine jungs sind ja das sei natürlich
genau
so sehr die hoffnung die große hoffnung
in seiner verzweiflung wandte er sich an
new york einen pensionierten
kantonspolizisten der heute aus privater
ermittler tätig ist und die fährte der
verschwundenen kinder aufgenommen hat im
moment haben wir es nicht unbedingt gute
der hand der mutter mit dem kind haben
wir ziemlich lang haben wir sie im brief
auge und hand höchst wo sie sich
aufhalten dort und jetzt ziemlich
unverhofft hat sie wohnort verlag und
ist zurzeit mit dem spurlos verschwunden
können sie davon aus dass sie wieder
findet ja auch bei überzeugt dass man
sie wieder weit findet über den
zeitpunkt ist alter plötzlich wenig
somit das sage aber mir wäre jetzt
verschiedene maßnahmen ergriffen
technische robert auer witte thiel
michigan aussteller vor ort und spiel da
guter dinge dass wir der frau die mutter
mit dem kind wieder werden finden
peter schlagmüller muss derweil
versuchen im alltag weiter zu
funktionieren optimistisch zu bleiben
und geduld zu haben
nach über einem jahr ohne kontakt zu
seinen kindern fällt ihm das zusehends
schwerer schwierig sind situationen
wahltrend um mich immer hat also mumm
verhallt ich kann viele sind ja im dorf
freue mich dass ich kann mich und da
gibt es moment ja wurden sehr stark
parallelen zum ihnen damit das ist schon
verdammt was haben sie das gefühl eines
citrat wird zurücktreten
dann habe ich wieder jahre 21 16 bis 20
18 und damit direkt das halten zusammen
da muss ich gestehen heißt dass kunst
nicht gut
privatermittler jordi hat inzwischen ein
ganzes dossier zum vorschlag mit
zusammengestellt um die spur der kinder
und der frau wieder zu finden
konkret darum oder hat sich das
mitwissen zolls ort von der mutter vom
ex frau hand mehr wissen
transfair deren telefonnummern von einem
herrn dauerkontakt vor der ex frau was
ich heute schweiz dort wo jetzt weitere
auch nach russland spielt und autos die
wir natürlich jetzt auswerten und
überprüfen ob sie die ex-frau mit den
hütern einer kontakt wie drin in
verbindung steht und dass sap die häuser
julian wiederum anhaltspunkt auf ihren
aufenthalt dieses dossier hat der fluss
sich übersetzen lassen denn er arbeitet
nun mit russischen ermittlern zusammen
und möchte bald selber nach russland
reisen
[Musik]
doch dann kommt das corona virus und
legt den internationalen flugverkehr
lahm
[Musik]
russland reagiert unter anderem mit
teilweise strengen ausgangs
beschränkungen
ermittlungen vor ort müssen auf
unbestimmte zeit verschoben werden
eine hiobsbotschaft für peter schlag mit
denen das virus ins home office zwingt
ein wiedersehen mit seinen kindern ist
in weite ferne gerückt sie zum letzten
mal hat sich durchaus corona virus zu
dem anwalt wie die pandemie agnes lark
extrem verschlechtert auf englisch aber
doch bald ist dann wieder die sich auch
wieder nicht verändere es lieben und ihm
innere macht es wird wieder kraft
das ist mir nicht nur bezug bekommen das
hat dann wieder überwogen
dennoch muss man sagen ist es
schützenjugend das ganze wenn man hat
ihnen user keine zeithorizont wann jetzt
der erfolg eigentlich traurig es
vergehen gut fünf monate ohne
fortschritte und plötzlich geht alles
ganz schnell
nur über 20 20 peter schlagmüller
befindet sich in begleitung eines
russischen reporters kollegen auf dem
weg nach sankt petersburg zu einem
gerichtstermin
ich hoffe schwer dass ich meine kinder
nach bald zwei jahren
bitte sehen und umarmen kann das ist
mein innigster wunsch
[Musik]
erreichen will er das mit hilfe des so
genannten hacker abkommens das auch
russland unterzeichnet hat dieses soll
die sofortige rückgabe widerrechtlich in
einem vertragsstaat verbraucht oder dort
zurückgehaltenen kinder sicherstellen
dass seine kinder ende 2018
widerrechtlich nach russland gebracht
und seither dort zurückgehalten werden
hat ein schweizer gericht so
festgestellt
die große frage ist nun sieht es ein
russisches gericht gleich und zwingt die
mutter dazu die kinder herauszugeben
nicht voreingenommen zugunsten der
mutter ja sie sollen die lage einfach
authentisch einschätzen und entscheiden
die zum wohle der kinder dokumente der
russische anwälte haben diese
verhandlung für ihn erreicht seine frau
wurde inzwischen gefunden allerdings
nicht durch den privatermittler sondern
durch die russischen behörden
sie wurde für heute vorgeladen taucht
aber nicht auf denn sie sei am corona
virus erkrankt heißt es es ist eine
kurze verhandlung mit folgendem fazit
enttäuschend für einen schweizerischen
vater ich fühle
momentan sagen wir mal ziemlich viel
leere
außer spesen nichts gewesen
zu einem gespräch mit seiner frau kommt
es nicht die geschenke die er für die
kinder mitbrachte kann er wieder mit
nach hause nehmen
das gerichtsurteil aus der schweiz dass
ihm in allen punkten recht gab ist hier
wertlos die kinder beide russisch
schweizerische doppelbürger sollen nach
rund zwei jahren nicht aus ihrem
lebenssituation herausgerissen werden
argumentiert das russische gericht
und dann das plötzlich eine sms seiner
frau mit sehr förmlicher anrede sehr
geehrter herr schlagmüller ich bin
bereit friedens zu unterschreiben
mit alle männer zogen und besuchstermine
wo findet das treffen statt
ich bin überrascht ich bin doch
überrascht dass sie schreibt dollar
sie haben einen account in skype
geöffnet nach einem jahr
keystone
[Musik]
schießt
das material ist schwieriger moment ist
sie will mich nur um den finger wickeln
ist ihre taktik
heute sie wollten ja
[Musik]
gott
ja heute
peter schlagmüller macht sich sogleich
auf den weg zum vereinbarten treffpunkt
dort will er nicht nur seine frau
sondern vor allem seine kinder endlich
wieder sehen
zuerst möchte ich sie umarmen und sagen
dass ich sie ganz fest lieb haben
den rest werden wir sehen
trotz angeblicher sowie der erkrankung
taucht seine frau auf alleine der
russische reporter kollege beobachtet
vom nebentisch aus eine emotionale
begrüßung und ein kurzes treffen
der gemeinsame weg zu beschreiten sieht
sie nur wenn sie einige unterzeichnete
vereinbarung dass sie gelder hält von
mir bekommt sonst funktioniert es nicht
mit den kindern finde ich absurd
schließlich
[Musik]
es ist eine juristische pattsituation
schlagmüller hat in der schweiz recht
bekommen seine frau in russland
nun müssen die beiden wohl oder über
versuchen sich irgendwie zu finden
vor allem auch in finanzieller hinsicht
am nächsten morgen hat sich die
situation bereits wieder verändert seine
frau habe sich nun doch bereit erklärt
ihm ein wiedersehen mit den kindern zu
ermöglichen und zwar schon heute
ich denke nach der überraschenden
gestrigen begegnung sehr emotional war
hat das auch bei ihr spuren hinterlassen
und zu gedanken anlass gegeben
und ja ich glaube wichtig ist dass wir
den fokus nicht verlieren nämlich das
kindeswohl ob das treffen mit seinen
söhnen wirklich stattfinden wird ist
unklar
schlagmüller rechnet mit allem und wenn
es zum wiedersehen kommt wie werden die
kinder reagieren
immerhin haben die inzwischen vier und
sechsjährigen buben ihren vater seit
zwei jahren nicht mehr gesehen
noch kennen
treffpunkt ist die schule der kinder der
russische reporter kollege filmt vom
autohaus wir schließlich tatsächlich zum
lange ersehnten wiedersehen kommt
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen schlagmüller meldet
sich per sms
er habe die letzte nacht in der wohnung
seiner frau schlafen dürfen mit den
kindern in den armen
heute sei er den ganzen tag mit ihnen
unterwegs
er sei überglücklich
[Musik]
nachdem er in sein hotel zurückgekehrt
ist treffen wir ihn wieder den kindern
geht es gut das eis schnell gebrochen
obwohl die buben nur noch sie sprechen
[Musik]
40 40
ja wir reden jetzt von einer
komfortablen ausgangslage sie ist
vollkommen deeskaliert die mutter
signalisiert auch weiterhin regelmäßigen
kontakt plötzlich die social media
kontakte sind jetzt plötzlich wieder
offen
sie blockiert nichts mehr ab ich bin
jetzt erstaunt ob das so weitergeht
und das wäre schön wenn wir wöchentlich
zwei drei mal übers web video call
führen können das wäre super
weihnachten 2020 bei peter schlagmüller
gibt es spaghetti und crevetten gefeiert
wieder alleine die kinder hat er nicht
zurück bekommen
trotzdem sind schöne festtage für ihn
denn er hat nun regelmäßige
videotelefonate mit seinen söhnen
irgendwann plötzlich in dem fall hat das
wieder erlaubte kanal ich hoffe sie
machen plötzlich wieder retten
miteinander logische wie es steckt aber
dann die pekuniäre vorträge die kinder
mit unterhalt und alimente als ihm im
fall ist das eine chance dass man eine
tragfähige lösung bringen
offen ist wie viel geld fließen muss
damit der kontakt bestehen bleibt
schlagmüller ist sicher dass man sich
finden wird irgendwie und irgendwann im
interesse der kinder perspektive heißt
konsolidiere vor dem zustand wo sich
jetzt ärgert widerrufbar festiger bezirk
also der gaga sieht die mütterliche sie
zu fall aufrechterhalten kind wieder hin
so behandle wie sie sich das gewöhnt
sind mit dem papier einfach nicht für
andere einfach die beziehung
aufrechterhalten
mit richtige witzig doch vorsicht was er
noch nicht amt schon bald wird wieder
alles anders sein
flughafen st petersburg ende januar 2021
ist zurück in russland und hat
neuigkeiten positiv
sie hat wieder komplett zur gemacht der
zugang verwehrt und fordert nur geld
geld für menschlich
ob es eine geschenk übergeben kann ist
unklar
außerdem sehr gern hans-peter schweizer
biblis
und dann führt billig der könig hat joel
sobald das buch oder sind die frühen die
träge was mit ihnen machen und es
marburg über schweizer konten ab
ja das war es
[Musik]
keine antwort mit
mein gott
weil ihr ihren geld forderungen nicht
nachgekommen ist hat seine frau wieder
jeglichen kontakt zu den kindern
unterbunden schlagmüller will trotzdem
vorbei gehen auch wenn er ausdrücklich
unerwünscht ist
ein paar stunden später meldete er sich
per telefon er habe seine kinder auf dem
spielplatz getroffen
dann sei es eine frau aufgetaucht und
habe sie mit in die wohnung genommen
drinnen hätten die kinder gewarnt
draußen habe er geweint
am nächsten morgen hat er ein hotel
direkt neben der schule der kinder
bezogen um ihnen wenigstens so nahe sein
zu können
die gestrigen ereignisse hätten ihn
traumatisiert
vor allem die weinenden kinder die
versucht hätten zu schlichten
jetzt bin ich irgendwie leer ich bin so
erschöpft
also viel bringt also für mich ganz
speziell wieder gefassten wir total leer
und frustriert und musiker kampf für
familien schlagmüller will einen letzten
versuch unternehmen mit seiner frau ins
gespräch zu kommen
darum kehrt er dorthin zurück wo er
gestern hemmungslos weinte ohne damit
etwas erreicht zu haben
ich glaube sicher bedienen aber sie
macht nur doof
gemen
ja ich glaube jetzt raumes langsam da
für das wochenend abschluss dankes vom
ritter aus erledigt aluh ah
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gut zwei monate später eine mediation
für die er mehrmals nach russland reiste
sei gescheitert weil die finanziellen
forderungen im ressort bekanntgeworden
seien
der kontakt zu den kindern ist
abgebrochen
ein riese reiss war nicht drin aber das
endziel am mini sind als vater an astro
in würde und das was die zwei worte für
die ihren tante habe bis jetzt geschafft
obwohl alles daran gesetzt hat dass ich
extrem frustrierend mit der frage was
das beste für kinder ist in einer so
hoffnungslosen situation ist er im
internet auf die stiftung für kinder in
der schweiz gestoßen mit romeo matschie
dem gründer hat sich einer austausch
entwickelt das erste persönliche treffen
findet im stiftungs sitz in hergiswil
stadt für schlagmüller der letzte
strohhalm
nachdem er seine juristischen
möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft hat ich
glaube jede aggressive vorn wo man die
jetzt zum einsatz bringen
das war kontraproduktiv sie und ich bin
überzeugt oder auch die kinder hatte das
gefühl ich schon immer dass kinder
instrumentalisiert werden denn die
geschichte reagiert und den gastraum
alle vorteile eines trauma wo sie gerade
zum ausdruck bringen oder das trauma wo
sich ihr sport gezeigt und dass das muss
man einfach vermieden
das kann auch bedeuten zu akzeptieren
dass man als vater viel zahlen soll
aber die kinder kaum sehen darf das
eindeutig wie sehr oft vater wurde eine
art rinde sind so kennt oder wo der
nacht ein effektiv lied oder und denn
sich sozial zurückzieht nehmen ist 80
dem glaube dort alles über ein darüber
tier und der das ganz wichtig
die city gefahren bezugsperson hätte
einfach moment fantastische lüthi der
schweiz wo das vig professionell
begleiten luft zeige dass wir aus der
situation auch wurde mit musi mindset
muss man für andere und auch wieder sage
was ich mich ziel um individuell und ich
wollte einfach dass vater oder mutter
zeigen ich hau mini verantwortlich so
gut wie gar nicht klappt und ich bei
anständig und korrekt wichtigste ist
dass er bin immer auf der lösungsfindung
bliebe und der fokus nicht abschalten
immer nach vorne lagen
aber ja die jahre die monate
verstreichen mann versuchten immer
wieder den kopf des betrags sie aber es
handelt sich einfach nicht zum guten
was wohl weitermachen aber der unbändige
wille wo ich mir die innenhand familien
dort sie ja die absicht noch als
schlussendlich und ja was jetzt siegen
wir die fünf jahr wird sie dann immer
noch ähnlicher punkt stöhnt hoffe ich
einfach nach war im worst-case-szenario
weiß mehr nicht
du hast doch noch ich sage jetzt
forschen ewigkeit aber derart häufig
nicht an kritische erzählt mich dass er
wieder habe das ist jetzt viel viel zeit
und viele tränen hat in der mehr als
zweijährige kampf um seine kinder
gekostet aber auch viel geld bisher rund
250000 franken ein happy end ist nicht
in sicht
[Musik]